Speaker 1: Last week, I had this video
for you of UFC fighter Bryce Mitchell
saying he knows nothing about Ukraine and Russia,
and then he listed a bunch of conspiracies.
He was naturally invited on to Tucker
Carlson's show to give his expertize.
Just as a reminder, here's the original
viral clip from UFC fighter Bryce Mitchell,
which we looked at last week. I just wanted
Speaker 2: to get your thoughts on the
whole Russia and Ukraine situation.
Speaker 8: You know, here's my first
thought is I'm not going nowhere to fight.
None of these words for these politicians.
I'm staying at home. And when the war comes to
Arkansas, I will take my boots on the ground
and I will die for everything I love and I
will not retreat if this country is invaded
and everybody saying, Well, we got to, we got to
evacuate, we got to leave, we got. I will not.
I will dig my boots in Arkansas soil and
I will fight for the people that I love
for the land that I love in a way, a life that
I love. But I'm not going overseas to fight. I
don't know what's going on, to be honest, brother.
I really don't. There's so much stuff, and I don't
think nobody knows what's going on fully. There's
been so much political corruption in that area.
You got Biden and his son making a shit ton of
money off of and using our tax dollars to bribe
their people. That's treasonous, in my opinion.
Speaker 1: OK. So he said, remember, he doesn't
know what's going on, but then he gave a
whole bunch of unsubstantiated opinions.
So of course, he gets the hero's welcome
on Tucker Carlson's program. No question
whatsoever. And let's take a look at that
Speaker 3: coming on in for what you said.
I haven't seen anybody express it
better than you did. Why didn't
you say that?
Speaker 8:
Well, thank you so much for having me, brother,
and I said that because that's the first thing
that I thought when he asked me and I was trying
to give him the best answer that I could, and
that's just my genuine thoughts on the subject.
Speaker 3: How do you get to be so honest
when everyone, everyone else is
afraid to say what they really get?
Speaker 1: And I mean. Tucker Tucker
should be blushing over this, guys.
Speaker 3: And you just kind of say it.
Speaker 8:
Well, I don't have to be worried about being
fired from my job for saying what I want to say,
there's a lot of people out there that do agree
with me, but they can't say things that I get
to say, even though they think they'll get fired
from their job if they come out and say it right.
Speaker 1: Cancel culture
Speaker 8: is pretty good with
how he lets us talk and say, we want
Speaker 3: that is that is absolutely
right and a fair thing to say. Now, people who
say what you have said are often denounced as
unpatriotic or traitors to their country.
Does that confuse you? Since the first thing
you said was I will fight and die for Arkansas,
Speaker 1: by the way, the they're pretending
the controversy over this guy is that he
said he wouldn't go and fight in Ukraine.
That's not really the controversy the controversy
is, he says. I don't know anything about what's
going on and I don't think anybody does, which
is a classic move from these people to say no.
Anything you're hearing is probably not true.
But then he spreads disinformation conspiracy
theories. That's the problem. Not that he
doesn't want to go and fight over there.
Speaker 8: That may be the greatest honor
I could ever have, brother. So I'm far from
not being a patriot, you know, that'd be the
greatest thing I could do is die defending this
land, so I'm not afraid to do that. I'm just not
wanting to go waste my life fighting for some of
these battles that I don't even believe in.
Speaker 1: That's great
that nobody's criticizing him for that.
Speaker 8: You know, I believe our leaders,
a lot of these elites are guilty of treason.
What they've done is just treasonous.
Speaker 1: Right? And again, he just gets into
this what, who, who did treason and what exactly
when. In the last segment he mentioned treason.
He was talking about Joe and Hunter Biden. That's
the treason. And this is exactly how people who
don't know anything end up in positions where
they're telling millions of people about
their ignorant beliefs. Remember, he said,
I don't know what's going on there and
then went on to give all sorts of different
statements about what he thinks
is going on. And he was wrong
about all of it. He doesn't want to fight great.
Lots of people don't. That makes a lot of sense.
Why would you go over and fight there that
you don't have to do that? It's not the
moral test you have to pass. But then he repeats
all of this nonsense, and then Tucker brings him
on to repeat it again. It's really dangerous stuff
that's going on right now in right wing media.